[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian sieers einen guten
Samstagabend ihnen allen bzw eine gute
Nacht muss man ja fast schon sagen wir
bringen Sie auf den neuesten Stand der
Nachrichten und müssen beginnen mit dem
Krieg in Nahost der auch ein Nervenkrieg
ist die einen können aufatmen viele
andere müssen weiter bangen die
eigentlich geplante Übergabe weiterer
israelischer Geiseln aus der Hand der
Hamas hatte sich den ganzen abendüber
verzögert dann endlich vor etwas mehr
als einer Stunde hat deren Freilassung
geklappt es ist erlaubt sich zu freuen
und es ist erlaubt zu weinen sagt Joni
Ascher der schon seit gestern Abend
seine beiden zwei und vier Jahre alten
Töchter seine Frau und deren Mutter
zurück hat in seinen Armen aus Tel Aviv
Dominik
lesmeister Fahrzeuge des Roten Kreuzes
am Grenzübergang Rafa am Nachmittag
hatte Hamas noch verzögert nun kommen 13
Israelis und vier thailändische
Staatsbürger frei kurze Zeit sah es
danach aus als ob die Vereinbarung mit
Hamas bereits nach einem Tag
platzt dabei brachte die erste
geiselfreilassung gestern so viel
Hoffnung der ne
kann seinen Vater wieder in den Arm
nehmen auch seine Mutter wurde
freigelassen und seine Familie wieder
vereint in einem israelischen
Krankenhaus nach fast 7 Wochen
Geiselhaft auch Jonny Ascher konnte
seine Frau und seine beiden kleinen
Töchter in die Arme schließen sie sind
auch deutsche
Staatsbürger ich freue mich dass ich
meine Familie zurückbekommen habe aber
ich werde nicht Feier bis der letzteon
zurückgekommen Freude aber auch Schmerz
denn zahlreiche freigelassene erfahren
erst jetzt dass Familienmitglieder durch
den hamasterror getötet wurden nun geht
es darum vor allem die freigelassenen
Kinder intensiv zu
betreuen die Kinder und ihre Familien
sind in guter körperlicher Verfassung es
ist noch zu früh mehr über ihren
emotionalen Zustand zu sagen alle werden
von interdisziplinären Teams
betreut im Gegenzug hat Israel gestern
auch 39 palästinensische Häftlinge
freigelassen Frauen und Jugendliche sie
waren für Strafen von leichten vergehen
bis zu tarunterstützung inhaftiert
cousse ist dem Januar für 15 Monate
Gefängnis verurteilt worden er habe
Israels Sicherheit gefährdet im Rahmen
der Vereinbarung ist der nun auf freiem
Fuß Frühstück mit seinen Eltern im
Westjordanland es ist ein
unbeschreibliches Gefühl Gott sei Dank
bin ich bei meiner Familie und bei
meiner Mutter und meinem Vater das
bedeutet für mich
in telaviv versammelten sich heute Abend
Zeus Angehörige und Freunde der Geiseln
der Museumsplatz heißt inzwischenplatz
der entführten sie wollen dass alle
zurückkommen ich bin keine Staatsfrau
oder Politikerin aber ich denke Sie
sollten alles tun um sie gesund
zurückzubringen so schnell wie
möglich der Weg des Friedens ist immer
besser aber wenn man nicht die richtigen
Partner hat muss man tun was man tun
muss um sicherzugehen dass alle zu ihren
Familien
zurückkehren Israels Politiker betonen
immer wieder dass sie alle Geiseln
zurückbringen wollen der
Verteidigungsminister beim Truppenbesuch
im Norden des Gazastreifens die
Botschaft die geiselfreilassung sei ein
Ergebnis des Militäreinsatzes die erste
Gruppe von Geisel nach Hause zu bringen
ist das Ergebnis militärischen Drucks
sobald militärischer Druck ausgeübt wird
will eine Pause wenn man den Druck
erhöht wollen sie eine weitere Pause
wenn man den Druck noch weiter erhöht
sind Sie bereit ein Angebot zu
unterbreiten zwischen Hoffen und Bangen
das Gefühl vieler Angehörigen der
Geiseln denn jeder Tag kann eine
Zitterpartie
werden ja wie sehr das alles auf der
Kippe steht und wirklich ein echter
Nervenkrieg ist das haben wir heute
wieder gesehen L walport ist für uns
live in Tel Aviv l guten Abend wie ist
denn jetzt der aktuelle Stand bei dieser
zweiten Gruppe von freigelassenen
Geiseln also die gute Nachricht ist die
Geiseln sind alle inzwischen auf
israelischenem Boden eingetroffen über
den Umweg Ägypten und wir können auch
bestätigen oder jedenfalls die
israelischen bürden haben das bestätigt
dass es sich um 13 Geiseln handelt
israelische und vier thailändische und
unter den 13 sind unter anderem auch
vier mit deutschenem pass ich schau mal
eben auf die Namen das ist eine Mutter
Adi schoham mit den 3 8 Jahre alten
Kindern neve und jahel und dann eine
Rentnerin schosan Haran also das ist die
gute Nachricht wirwarten jetzt noch in
den kommenden Minuten oder Stunden auch
die Freilassung der 39 palästinensischen
Häftlinge aus israelischen Gefängnissen
und dann wäre dieser Tag jedenfalls nach
all den Aufregungen und der Ungewissheit
unter Dach und Fach jetzt gibt es lü
heute auch Meldungen nach denen
möglicherweise in den kommenden Tagen
mehr Geiseln als ursprünglich geplant
freikommen könnten und die Waffenruhe
dementsprechend auch verlängert wird wie
wahrscheinlich ist
das ja da gibt es heute Abend sicher
viele Fragen denn das war ja doch ein
ziemlicher Nervenkrieg wir haben das
heute gesehen aus israelischer Sicht
also die israelische Darstellung ist die
Hamas stellt immer wieder neue
Forderungen hält sich also nicht
wirklich an das was vereinbart wurde
genau umgekehrt sieht das die Hamas sie
sagt die Israelis halten die
Vereinbarungen nicht ein unter anderem
komme kein Treibstoff und keine
Lebensmittel in den Norden des
Gazastreifens das sei aber vereinbart
also da ist vieles offen viel ist
offenbar noch im Fluss und es bedürfte
heute z.B eines Telefonats des
US-Präsidenten beiden mit dem Emir von
Qatar um Druck zu machen auf beiden
Seiten dass das doch noch vorank kommt
also die Frage ob diese vierägig
vereinbarte Feuerpause noch verlängert
wird die gibt es
Israel hat das nicht komplett abgelehnt
oder ausgeschlossen aber er stellen sich
heute doch mehr Fragen und die bleiben
erst einmal unbeantwortet ich glaube man
muss mal sehen wie morgen der Tag sich
angeht und ob dann morgen alles glatter
läuft als heute vielen Dank für diese
Information ganz aktuell live aus Tel
Aviv und damit nach Deutschland die
Grünen hatten heute abend wenig Zeit für
Wetten das auf den späteren Samstagabend
hatte die Regie ihres Parteitags ein
Thema mit Sprengkraft gelegt die
Migrationspolitik bei der von den
Pragmatikern in der Partei längst ein
neuer Sound zu hören ist während die
Basis Sorge hat dass so von einem
weiteren grünen Kernthema nur noch wenig
übrig bleibt eine erbitterte Debatte
innerhalb der Grünen Partei und durchaus
möglich dass sie auf den Parteitag heute
überzieht Andreas Hoper und Thomas
Reichard haben
mehr als das Thema Migration endlich zur
Debatte aufgerufen wird da dauert der
Parteitag schon ungefähr 30 cm oder über
10 Stunden vieles diskutiert worden über
Europa über Krieg und Frieden über
Gerechtigkeit und Wohlstand das Thema
Asyl und bringt nicht nur ordentlich
Stimmung sondern Streit in den Saal sehr
sehr viele wollen zum Thema sprechen am
Ende werden 20 ausgelost auch die
Außenministerin weiß um die Brisanz des
Themas in ihrer Partei ohne Ordnung gibt
es keine
Humanität wenn wir nicht wissen wer
kommt ihn registrieren wie soll er oder
sie
dann verteilt werden können und bleiben
können Ordnung heißt für die Parteilinke
Verschärfung viele der Basis wollen
keine härteren zuwanderungsregeln nicht
für Deutschland nicht für Europa es ist
unehrlich von Ordnung zu reden werden
täglich im Mittelmeer Menschen
sterben bitte lass uns die Partei
bleiben die eben nicht sagt wir müssen
im großen Stil abschieben sondern die
Partei sagt kein Mensch ist illegal die
Grüne Jugend hat einen Antrag zur
Abstimmung gestellt der will alle
Ministerinnen und Minister alle
Abgeordneten der der Grünen verpflichten
keine asylrechtsverschärfung zuzustimmen
denn dieser Kurs ist nicht nur moralisch
falsch sondern auch
strategisch und deshalb aus moralischer
aus strategischer Sicht es gibt keinen
Grund für weitere
asylrechtsverschärfung wenn wir nicht
mit am Tisch gesessen hätten dann gäbe
es nicht mehr Geld für die kommun denn
wiren die einzigste Partei in der
Bundesregierung die sich dafür
eingesetzt hat und wenn wir in Zukunft
nicht am Tisch sitzen werden wird sich
nichts in die positive
richtungentwickeln des ja das Signal ist
angekommen ihr wollt uns kämpfen sehen
wir wollen kämpfen wir wollen nicht das
Ende dieser Regierung wir wollen den
Anfang einer anderen Asylpolitik das
sieht der Vizekanzler an dass man
regiere nun mal nicht alleine man müsse
Kompromiss eingehen auch wenn es
schmerzt es wäre naiv zu glauben dass
das möglich ist ohne in einer Regierung
zu verbleiben insofern ist die Wahrheit
dass dieser Antrag auffordert die
Regierung zu verlassen nach zwei Tagen
relativer Einigkeit beim Thema Migration
zeigt sich grünes Streitpotenzial ist
durchaus vorhanden auch wenn sich am
Ende die Parteispitze durchsetzt und der
Antrag der Grünen Jugend abgelehnt
wird so und was heute auch noch wichtig
war hier ist die Nachrichtenübersicht
mit dir Heinz die CSU geht mit Manfred
Weber als Spitzenkandidat in die
Europawahl Weber ist Vorsitzender der
Europäischen Volkspartei und der EVP
Fraktion im Europaparlament eine
csu-degierten Versammlung in Nürnberg
wählte ihn heute auf Platz 1 der
csu-liste für die Europawahl im Juni
Weber rief erneut zu einer europäischen
Lösung für die Migrationsfrage
auf Russland hat die Ukraine erneut
massiv angegriffen nach ukrainischen
Angaben gab es in der vergangenen Nacht
den bisher größten Drohnenangriff Ziel
sei vor allem Kiev gewesen mehr als 70
drohen würden demnach auf Kiev
abgefeuert die meisten konnten
abgeschossen werden in Kief vielen
Trümmer auch auf Wohngebäude fünf
Menschen wurden dort
verletzt deutschland ist einer der
größten militärischen Unterstützer der
Ukraine auch dagegen gingen heute in
Berlin mehrere tausend Menschen auf die
Straße sie demonstrierten gegen
Rüstungspolitik und Waffenexporte auch
palästinensische Flaggen waren zu sehen
als
hauptnrednerin trat die frühere
linkenpolitikerin Wagenknecht auf sie
warf der israelischen Regierung eine
Zitat rücksichtslose Kriegsführung im
Gazastreifen
vor der Deutsche Frauenrat hat
anlässlich des internationalen Tages
gegen Gewalt an Frauen darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass der gefährlichste Ort für
Frauen das eigene zu Hause sei nach
Zahlen der Vereinten Nationen wurde im
vergangenen Jahr weltweit fast 89 000
Frauen und Mädchen vorsätzlich getötet
die höchste Zahl seit 20 Jahren weltweit
gingen wie hier in Madrid Tausende auf
die Straße um ein Zeichen zu setzen sie
fordern besseren Schutz für Betroffene
in vielen Fällen geht die Gewalt vom
Partner oder Expartner
aus mehr als se Jahrzehnte stand
Heidelinde weiß auf der Bühne und vor
der Kamera nun ist die österreichische
Schauspielerin im Alter von 83 Jahren
gestorben dem breiten Publikum wurde
Heidelinde weiß vor allem durchs
deutsche Fernsehen bekannt in
zahlreichen Gastrollen z.B im
Traumschiff oder bei Rosamunde Pilcher
oder in der schwarzwallklinik die Folgen
mit ihr können Sie übrigens in der ZDF
Mediathek
sehen während die Bundesregierung mit
einem Loch im Haushalt von mindestens 60
Milliarden klarkmen muss setzt der
Handel in Deutschland darauf in den
Wochen vor Weihnachten möglichst viel
einzunehmen es ist die wichtigste Zeit
im Jahr an der Werbung für den Black
Friday schnäppchentag aus dem J längst
eine ganze Aktionswoche geworden ist
kommt auch wirklich niemand mehr vorbei
aber die Vorzeichen für ein rauschendes
Konsumfest sind dennochch alles andere
als gut Deutschland in Kauflaune dieses
Jahr wohl eher nicht Alexander Pool mit
mehr vier Wochen vor Weihnachten viele
Schaufenster in München festlich
geschmückt laut Handelsverband stehen in
diesem Jahr Bücher weit oben auf der
Einkaufsliste die Buchhandlung von
Michael lemmling hat das Jahr ganz gut
überstand
jetzt Hof auf das Weihnachtsgeschäft na
ja das ist die große entscheidende
Nummer am Ende des Jahres wenn sie ze
Monate eigentlich ganz gut über die
Runden gekommen sind und das
Weihnachtsgeschäft geht schief dann ist
das Ganze jah futsch der Handelsverband
Deutschland dämpft die Erwartungen an
die letzten Wochen des Jahres die
Experten gehen lediglich von einem
geringen Wachstum von 1,5% aus rechnet
man die Inflation mit ein könnte am Ende
sogar ein Minus von 5,5% stehen das hat
auch viel zu tun mit Psychologie mit
Stimmung aufgrund der außenpolitischen
Gegebenheiten die wir erleben
beispielsweise der aufflammenden
ostkonflikt aber auch der andauernde
russische Krieg in der Ukraine sind
beides sehr belastende Dinge das macht
sich wohl auch bei den Ausgaben
bemerkbar für Weihnachtsgeschenke wie
Spielzeug Bücher oder Schmuck wollen 13%
der deutschen deutlich weniger ausgeben
als im Vorjahr etwa die Hälfte hat
genauso viel eingeplant nur 2% wollen
deutlich mehr
ausgeben das wird nicht ganz so groß
ausfallen in von Geschenke her aber ich
werde immer gleich bleiben ein bisschen
weniger würde ich sagen aber gerne das
was wir gibt gibt mir gerne man muss
schon besparen durch die Energiekosten
die jetzt gestiegen sind ne muss man
schon ein bisschen zurückstecken ja
trotz glitzernder Auslagen das
Weihnachtsgeschäft wird für den Handel
in Deutschland wohl kein Fest
werden und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags die lauten wie immer ohne
Gewehr
327 32 35 38 47 Superzahl 5 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotte.zdfde
und im ZDF Text auf Seite
556 die Wetteraussichten für morgen es
Schneid morgen im Süden anfangs noch
später wird der Schneefall dort weniger
von Nordwesten drängen neue Regen und
Schneewolken ins Land maximal 0 bis 7°
in den nächsten Tagen bleibt es
winterlich kalt und wechselhaft mit
Schnee und Regen zwischendurch gibt es
auch Sonnenschein bei maximal -3 bis +
7° ja das war also das letzte mal wetten
das mit Thomas gotschalk morgen früh
wenn die Einschaltquoten kommen werden
wir wissen wie viele Menschen sich das
nicht entgehen lassen wollten was wir
uns jetzt schon angucken können wie
gotschalk selbst gerade eben direkt nach
seiner großen Abschiedsshow auf das
blickt was jetzt kommt ach ich habe mich
ja lange genug geistig darauf vor itet
es muss weitergehen es geht in allen
Geschäften weiter und es haben sich die
die Fiaker Fahrer in Wien haben sich an
die Taxis gewöhnen müssen die Taxis
haben sich an uber gewöhnen müssen und
ich muss mich daran gewöhnen dass andere
Dinge jetzt wichtiger sind als das
Samstagabend Fernsehen allerletzte Frage
wie lässt du den Abend jetzt heute
ausklingen na ja ZF typisch gibt es
jetzt noch Bier und Currywurst
wahrscheinlich das klingt gut es gibt
bestimmt kein
Champagne denkwürdiger Showabend für
dieses Land geht zu Ende wir sagen DANKE
für heute und freuen uns auf Sie morgen
21:45 Uhr Wiedersehen
[Musik]
tschüss